okay now okay some people ask you about
like interval live that kind of thing
for the sake of argument when they say
chord PQ usually they're referring to
the actual whole life that passes do it
okay
so yes when I look at the chord it's
just that portion right but if I
extended it really does pass through
this point is outside the crosswalk okay
by the way outside it inside that
distinction is going to become in the
important in a minute okay because it's
a nice convenient way of distinguishing
between two regions which it does
actually divide the Cartesian plane into
so I mean suppose you could call it up
and down but inside outside feels
natural
alright now there's the question what's
the law yourself a new point of P okay
now I haven't taught it to you the
question but usually you'd need to
define some point which is all the
points which are on these lockers right
so 6/7 midpoint I'm going to call it and
so let the midpoint be and I'd usually
call it pay right but piece taken
already so just have to do okay now
since the lock is moves around that's
why it's X&Y and they're very move okay
so we're gonna find out what the
relationship between these two is and
that'll give us laws okay now you've
been doing this for a little while
without me let's see how much you've
learned
what I do well it must be your first
step I've just introduced em what would
you do finally great you know what
hmm okay now gradients an interesting
thing it's really important with the
parameter right because sometimes
depending on the parabola you've got the
parameter is the gradient okay now in
this case we actually know a lot about
this parabola already for instance
what's its focal length it was one right
now that tells you that when you've got
these P and these Q points write the
general form for any point on this
parabola ears well what is it each point
what are its Cartesian coordinates away
to AP AP squared which in our case right
so two P P squared
lower case right and likewise for Q now
I'm probably gonna suggest the gradient
here as an end result won't be that
useful okay because I'm looking for a
position more than actually how steep it
is okay so I don't leave gradient off
for now even though if I wanted to well
what is the gradient of this like say at
this point here if I drew attention in
what was raining
no you don't this is the whole point of
parametric it's pain thank you
that's why that's why P is useful or Q
okay cuz that's the gradient at that
point anyway that's the same point you
can drive it and it's not that hard
right here I'm not really interested in
its it's a trivial measure by let's move
on
you've seen to need some help sir Oh
walk it right it's a relationship
between these X's and these wires well
it would help if I knew what the X's and
Y's were right
so it's the mid-pipe to PQ I know what
the coordinates of P and Q are right so
what's X equal to if you want to find a
midpoint right how do you find the X
whenever midpoint
yeah you're gonna take the average of
these right so I'm gonna go in half to
pee across the street which as you said
is peat moss okay okay all right
what is that whatever I coordinate I do
it the same way right
I take these two y-coordinates I'll just
say the average right which is half
piece man okay now at the moment what
I've got is the parametric equations on
the lockers remember this parametric
version of lockets cuz I got the X in
terms of the parameters I've got the Y
in terms of the parameters and that's
sort of done right but I want to I want
to Cartesian equation right a single
equation rather than two because then I
can work out with restrictions will be
okay so how do I go from two equations
into one I have to do some kind of
substitution right what would you do if
I want to get X in terms of Y in terms
and X it's the same thing what would you
suggest I think I should square what the
X right not much you square this because
my police Quinn's and Q's kids will turn
into Peter the fours or whatever right
so I Square this let's do that x squared
okay
that's P plus Q or squared right so
that's P squared all right now this is
good
well at least it's it's better than what
we had before okay well I've stored some
problems okay you can see this P Square
and this Q squared I'll be able to sub
that out for this Y here it's just off
by a factor of two is that okay so far
yes but what do I do with this guy
am I gonna get rid of it because I
really I can't I can't unfortunately
just subtractive maybe put them on the
other side I've got to get rid of all my
parameters right so what other
information do I know that can help me
eliminate this 2pq a very valuable
contribution okay big thing I actually
already gave you a clue
what other information do we have which
can actually help us in this situation
these coordinates right they're gonna
figure in somehow okay
the question is how will I bring them in
to play it how will they help me if a
chord align right past us through some
point okay that geometrically that's
what it means but but how would you
break ly what that means is this is core
it has some equation right okay and that
means that when you have that equation
this pair of coordinates ought to
satisfy that equation you should be able
to x equals zero and wipers - to slap it
in whatever this is and and that will
come something okay okay now we did
discuss this before you do have to prove
these equations but let's just move on
does anyone remember what's the equation
of a chord PQ I'll give you a clue let's
go to here it starts with half P plus Q
X yep
yes which I said two minutes ago but I
want to answer the question and you guys
can I'm going to give you a sheet in a
second which is all the decorations in
doesn't give me the same I miss you
minus a P Q equals Sara who's confident
is a alternate yeah is that the way I
read it I actually wrote I usually write
the Y over here and they PQ over there
but it doesn't matter it's the same
equation let's go with it
okay now there's equation of the chord
you usually would have derived this okay
but let's assume we've just gotten there
it only takes a few lines okay what am I
gonna do with this I'm gonna sum two
things into here number one I'm gonna
sub in this point that we talked about
okay so there will be my X's there will
be my y's there's something else is
gonna sub you a which we know to be one
okay so let's go ahead and do that in
this case here a equals one x equals 0 y
equals -2 okay so off you go
this
what's hit a man speaking yeah yes right
there
why is my suit okay all right now that's
how fool cuz that P Q right that's
exactly what I need to get rid of over
here all right so now that I have that
in place I've got a little piece I need
this one x squared equals now I know
what Y it is why is half P squared plus
Q 2 min so I'll put that half over the
other side like so okay so what have I
got here
that's 2y and that is okay there's the
equation of the locus right now all
we've been saying all right just as with
the derivative of log X okay just
because you get an equation at the end
that doesn't mean that this is exactly
the lockers we're after
okay and the way you can know there's a
problem apart from when your teacher
puts a heading on the board that Clues
you into that fact is well let's let's
muck around with this a little bit if I
put this into a more standard form okay
which admittedly is not much of a change
what can you tell me about this parabola
specifically how is it different
through this parabola can we compare
these two alright number one there's a
shift okay and it's just a down that y
plus two means the vertex is no longer
at the origin right the vertex is here
actually that point we looked in before
okay so there's the first thing of shift
secondly I had a coefficient of four
here I have a coefficient 2 here what
difference does that make
it is steeper right there's a couple
ways to think about that I'm number one
it means the focal length is smaller
okay which also means the and I hate
having to say this person even happens
every year the latus rectum is enough
right it's thinner because it's based on
the focal length okay
so if this was that with before because
that's a to now it should be half the
wick it's a thinner steeper parabola
okay so here's what I've got let me get
on top if we move down and it's steeper
so I'm getting something like this okay
that is I should write on there x
squared equals 2y plus 4 - okay so you
tell me what's the problem good question
there will be in about 60 seconds what's
the problem can someone state it for me
let's just into a good ok so whatever
chords you draw okay let's just have a
messy problem over here once you take
all this court okay and you take the
midpoints of those that they may have in
common is all the midpoint up inside
inside the parabola okay and yet we've
got this weird section down here
which matches our equation right but it
clearly copy part of them long so that's
how you know it must be some
restrictions yeah why is he quitting
given - because the pucks that I do want
they do sure enough light up on this
equation okay yeah okay I'll probably
say because algebra all of this stuff
that we're doing here is manipulation
right it's never enough to tell you
which answers are writing which on the
wrong a little bit like no absolute
value right and you saw me one of these
things about something like that right
algebra will give you answers but it
will give you more answers than there
are right and you do everything correct
that's when you're going to do you've
got to do cases you have to test it up
or you'll look at the graph and you
that's not an answer because even though
the algebra told me one doesn't lie on
the ground okay so algebra is never
sufficient on its own that's why I drew
it actually question sorry
not quite there's actually a bit above
my cuisine like see this little shade in
there okay so but yeah I donate their
cost around
I haven't yet haven't now here's the
thing okay here's the question here's
the length and breadth of the question
that's always said I might've said
stayed any restrictions okay here's the
thing they don't tell you what the
restriction is you have to find what
they are right and the nature of the
question that it's the midpoint of a
chord that makes you think okay there
must be some kind of restriction on it
now the question is what is it okay now